the most powerful love potion in the
world
it's rumored to smile differently to
each person according to what attracts
them
for example i smell welcome back to the
things potterheads
when jk rowling gave us a peek into the
harry potter characters lives
19 years later we saw that hermione
granger had a family with ron weasley
but what if these gryffindors didn't end
up together we were imagining what it
would look like if good girl hermione
crossed over to slither inside and sell
for
bad boy draco malfoy instead after all
draco did show his softer side by the
end of the series
hermione could have seen hope for draco
and we all know how much she loves the
challenge
he was desperate to live a different
life away from his controlling family
and she was committed to turning him
from a villain into a good guy
just picture the sparks that fly between
these two former enemies when they
finally kissed
[Music]
do
[Music]
is
you're switching in your mind
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you